[Music]
so how you doing I'm doing great you
know just um she's doing needs to be
done what does that mean I'm sorry dad
um why don't we just have lunch and talk
we can do that right please you think
that you have this under control I
understand why I do things it doesn't
make me any different you're just
embarrassed because I was like you know
I was like this amazing thing like your
special creation or something and you
know like Who I am now yeah who are you
Nick this is me that here this is who I
am
this is not you this is not you Nick
what are you doing no you always got to
be controlling everything all the time
let me let me book you about at a hotel
for love night I want it to go like this
[Music]
my son has gone missing Nicholas chef sh
e FF there's no one by that name sir
there are moments that I look at him
this kid that I raised who I thought I
knew inside and out
and I wonder who is I thought we were
close I thought we were closer than most
fathers and sons why I felt I've ever
had so I just kept doing it this isn't
us this is not who we are
my son is out there somewhere and I
don't know what he's doing I don't know
how to help him you can't I don't feel
like I have a disease
this isn't like cancer this is my choice
I've poked myself here I failed I can't
do it alone
I need to find a way to fill this black
hole in me I stole them the family I
want to be proud of me
[Music]
what you have you're gonna find it again
you're gonna get it back
do you know how much I love you I love
you more than everything kind of
wrecking everything
everything
[Music]